Tony Dungy was tweeting up a storm last
night some of his tweets
I'm not saying officials cost lions the
game I'm saying three wrong calls in one
obvious missed call in one half is not
acceptable doesn't matter who wins the
game and the hall-of-famer joins us now
Tony how do we fix this if you're the
NFL and all the owners are meeting today
in Florida what would you tell them on
how to get this right well the first
thing I would suggest is full-time
officials I've kind of beat that but I'm
for twenty years when I was coaching and
to me every official should be in the
league office today looking at
everything that happened over the
weekend this is how we're going to call
things this is how we're not going to
call thing and it should be it should be
a full-time job and that's the first
thing and then the second thing I think
we've got to just get back to something
Chuck Noll used to say all the time we
have to call what we see and not have
agendas of hate you know safety is and
I'm all for safety but when you tell
these guys hey if it's close air on the
side of safety and you put that in their
mind and then you get calls like that
word defensive back last night it's
trying to make an interception you know
he gets a personal foul penalty and you
know I think we put too much in the
officials head instead of just saying
here's the rules now call what we see
and we'll won't be happy with it
but now they're talking about a sky
judge Tony what's that what's a sky
judge going to do I don't know Joe green
I was telling Fritzi Joe cream every
time he gets mad at their facility we
don't really need these guys we need one
person there he doesn't do anything but
spot the ball and then we have one fan
at home just watching it on TV and then
telling him what to do and sometimes you
look at and you say that that might be
better because there are things that we
saw on TV last night that just had you
shake your head but I think we we just
have to get back to letting these guys
officiate I thought it was really really
a bad thing when they put this pass
interference review in because when you
start reviewing judgment you know if you
review it will
the guy's foot on the line get the ball
across the plane and you can see pretty
clearly okay yes or no but when it has
to be clear and obvious well my judgment
you know one thing is clear and obvious
to me and in the way I'd read it and the
way I look at it is this hands to the
face no I don't think so but somebody
else's just for anybody you might say
well I did see some hands to the face
there and when they put that task
interference review in I saw this this
is going to lead down a bad path but
even it feels like coaches don't want to
challenge defensive pass interference
because they know the chances are won't
be overturned we saw it last night we
saw it last night obvious pass
interference penalty and you're saying
hey challenge that challenge that but as
the coach is sitting there and only one
out of the last 21 has gotten overturn I
feel like I'm wasting a timeout that I
might need so I'm not going to challenge
it it was clearly faster interference
the Dallas game on Sunday through some
written scores a touchdown they call
offensive pass interference for a pick
it's the wrong call absolutely and
you're saying hey Jason Garrett you need
to challenge that but he says you know I
told twenty others that were obvious but
didn't get overturned I'm not going to
waste my time out and you know to put a
rule in to say it's going to fix these
obvious bad calls and then it doesn't I
just I don't know what the purpose of
the rule is if I said and I took a vote
with the coaches right now and no names
attached and I said you want more replay
or get rid of replay all together how do
you think the coaches would vote that's
hard to say that they would say I want
more replay if we're going to get it
right but if we're going to use the
replay like it has been on this pass
interference just get rid of it because
it has really created more problems than
it's worth
hi for once when they put the replay in
in 1999 I I said it was a bad idea
I didn't like it didn't want it and the
first game we ever played they replayed
a call on a touchdown play it was wrong
and you know we got the apology
afterwards
sorry we missed I got a $10,000 fine
that day if we've got as I don't mind
you missing a call bang bang but when
you have two minutes to look at it and
ten angles and still get it wrong that's
bad officiating and it cost me 10 grand
and got my mother mad at me is that the
only time you got find in your coaching
career I learned a lesson right there
and when my mother called and said you
can't be criticizing people above your
Bible says respect you're not only their
elders but your superior so I had to I
had to bite my tongue after that but why
is it we overreacted to the Saints Rams
game and then we under react or at least
the NFL does to the regular-season games
these games these calls can mean a team
the difference in a team winning a game
making the playoffs getting home-field
advantage like there's a lot that's
attached to it but for some reason we
don't overreact to the regular season
well I agree with you Mike Florio you
know he he says hey Jason Garrett's on
the hot seat now something could have
happened with his a blow they lost the
game by two points that basically four
points got taken from them on a call
that we say we put this rule in to fix
and so why is he on the hot seat and why
can't we fix it if that's what it's
supposed to do and you see this over and
over that home field advantage playoff
spots winning seasons or just games for
some teams and some coats as they swing
and and I'm you know I don't blame the
officials but when when you put
something in and say this is supposed to
fix it there was an error in the game in
the RAM Saints we don't want to see that
again so we've got this to fix it and
then you don't fix it it doesn't make
sense talking to Tony Dungy the
hall-of-famer joining us on loan from
football night America
I asked this question yesterday to a
couple of guests and nobody really had
an answer who was the second best team
in the AFC right now you know I hate to
say it but it
be Buffalo it really might the chief
scare me with that defense
it has they're not getting the stops
that they need to put him way too much
pressure on their offense now you know
the the the south teams a lot of up and
down there
I love deshaun Watson but their defense
has been a little spotty as well Buffalo
doesn't have great offenses they're not
consistent on offense I think we gotta
wait another month to see I'm not sure
who the second-best can go and even the
Patriots even though they're undefeated
they don't feel undefeated because we're
not I mean like the offense that
offensive line they don't have weapons
they're the defense is really good but I
don't even know that's good yeah they
haven't bite anybody they played and
let's look the change they played and
you know maybe the defense is good they
look dominant right now but I think the
jury's still out on that and offensive
ly they're not the same they're you know
they're not in sync and precise like
you're used to seeing that that offense
in New England and and that may come but
I think the whole league is like that
really and I go back to lack of
preseason a lot of things I'm not sure
who's good right now who's your MVP
right now I'd have to say Russell Wilson
I look at them and they still had the
same problems with pass protection their
defense is up and down
everything that happens he's scrambling
around making plays improvising hasn't
thrown an interception yet he just seems
to make the play for them to win they're
five and one and they've got a lot of
old - I'm not sure they're a great team
so right now I'd lean towards Russell
but don't you think it's interesting how
we have a biased against quarterbacks
not taken in the first round that it
takes longer to anoint them because you
got dak Prescott and you got Russell
Wilson and it feels like there's this up
I think Russell Wilson has been as
valuable to his team as any player in
the last couple of years in the NFL and
that includes Brady and Patrick mahomes
all
those guys I think there's height ISM
where you know he doesn't fit into you
know for us at Wilson was six four and
then maybe went in the first round I
don't know but dak Prescott and Russell
Wilson we wait a while to anoint them
and certainly with Russ and it's taken
all these what is he eight years in and
we're still gone yeah he's pretty good
I'm like he's been great he has been
great he's done some unbelievable things
and and you're right we're preparing for
the Cowboys Eagles game and people are
asking well who would you rather have
and who's more valuable to the team
whence or Prescott and Prescott's been
out there every down he is played and
they haven't been been great and they've
had some some flaws and he's winning
games and he's doing a lot and no no one
wants to put him in the same breath as
Carson Wentz because you're right he's a
fourth ground pick and Carson was the
you know top of the draft but dak
Prescott has done some great things and
less this team very well so I kind of
agree with you Dan how does Jason
Garrett how do you block out what the
media says about you because they're we
we've been waiting for Jason Garrett to
get fired for a couple of years he's
been on the hot seat for you know a few
years like how do you block all about
that out in just coach you you can if
you had that relationship with your
owner and you know I think Jason has
that I know the guys in Pittsburgh had
that I was in Pittsburgh a long time the
fans would get upset and they still are
upset at my combo and but Mike can go in
and see it our our brownie office and
say hey here's what we're going to do
and mr. Rooney says yes yes yes and
here's where we're gonna go and then you
don't worry about it but if you don't
have that type of relationship then it
becomes hard to block out all the noise
because it's constant you hear it and
they're not sure could you ever see Mike
Tomlin well you could see him leaving
I'm sure Pittsburgh but joining
Washington know I first of all yeah if
you don't do that you don't leave a
stable situation where you've got that
ownership behind you and
history and tradition and go to a place
with a track record that says I'm only
going to be there two years it wouldn't
make sense and I absolutely would not
see my common doing that
were you ever broached with the
possibility of coaching the Steelers at
any point in your career
no no so even after kowler left you know
no Mike was the next guy so a Dan Rooney
called me we were actually preparing for
this Super Bowl and Dan called me and
said had I talked to this guy
you had him a little bit I want to hear
a little bit about him he really
impressed us and Mike was Dan's guy and
that was what was that 13 years ago 14
years ago and that's the way they do
things that there aren't many there
aren't many changes there aren't many
opportunities to coach the Steelers but
if they did call you if they called me
when I was young enough to do it I
definitely would have wanted to go there
yeah so prior to Cour no I know I'd
never talked to Dan in those terms at
all I was young
probably very young and I was incapable
City and when Bill got the job and
that's why I ended up going to to
Minnesota with Danny Green but then bill
kept the job for what 15 years so that
that's how it works they're still
amazing they've had three coaches you
know when you're in 45 years hey Tom
good to talk to you again oh well no but
if Pittsburgh doesn't want him any
longer that that's what I'm curious
about in that front office a long time
before Pittsburgh doesn't want him I can
tell you that there well tell the boys
on football night in America I said a
load Tony and of course the family hope
it's well I will talk to you soon
that's Tony Dungy Hall of Famer four
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR
five or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]